emergency crews in Nigeria are searching
for the bodies of dozens of people still
missing after a vote cap sized on Monday
night around 140 people were rescued but
more than 100 people are still
unaccounted for the accident happened on
the Niger River between the Niger and
kwara States police say the vessel was
carrying people returning from a wedding
and it's likely it was overloaded well
Ahmad Idris is joining us from the
village of egberti in Nigeria just close
to there I'ma just remind us what
happened with regard to this incident
well basically the the victims were like
you said in the introduction left a
wedding party very early in the morning
and so from the takeoff point to where
the boat sunk exactly where those young
men are is less than 200 meters
unfortunately because of the lateness of
their departure they want to save I
still like you said in the introduction
more than 100 people have been killed in
that accident and uh still dozens are
still missing now what these people are
doing these young men are doing uh
they've gone into the water trying to
attach ropes to the sunken boat which is
three times the size of this one that we
have here and use the boat we're in and
two other boats to drag the other boat
the sunken boat ashore and probably see
whether or not there are bodies more
bodies to be salvaged and be accorded uh
I write a proper burial Ahmed one would
imagine that this is a terrible blow to
the community there was is there any
response from the government in terms of
Rescue Services were they able to get
there in time
unfortunately no and um we we the
President issued a statement yesterday
that they he has ordered a proper
investigation as to the courses of This
Disaster and also send relief materials
to survivors and victims of the families
now 72 hours since this more than 72
hours since this accident the locals
here why this accident happened are
telling us that no official has arrived
the scene yet so what they're doing is
that they have deployed their own
resources the little resources they have
to try to pull up the boat and see
whether or not there are more bodies
that are under the water and then take
those uh to the cemetery and give them a
proper burial but the mood in the town
of uh Ebu is really devastating we spend
the night in that Community which is
just some 30 minutes boat ride from here
we spend the night there and in one
house close to where we were at least 18
members of that family have perished in
the boat accident in the house that we
stayed three people died and they're
still looking for more so the mood is
sort of very very sad in Ebu Village and
you're talking about nearly 10 percent
of the population has been wiped off by
this accident and the concern now is how
these people who find closure and
whether or not they recover from this a
lot of people who spoke to in that
Village say they don't think they will
recover anytime soon thank you very much
indeed Ahmad Idris talking to us from
both in Nigeria